>>> THE DOJ JUST FILING
A NEW COURT DOCUMENT IN THE
MAR-A-LAGO CASE ORDERING A
SPECIAL MASTER IS NOT NEEDED TO
REVIEW THE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS.
IT COMES AS A NEW REPORT, RIGHT
HERE IT IS, BY TEN PROMINENT
LEGAL MINDS CONCLUDES THERE'S
STRONG BASIS TO CHARGE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT FOR MISHANDLING
OF GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
THEY LAY OUT SIX CHARGES.
IN THEIR ANALYSIS THEY MODEL
WHAT THE DO DOJ WOULD PRESENT I
THEY INDICTED A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
RYAN, OUR VIEWERS ALL KNOW YOU.
YOU'RE IN HERE DAILY GIVING YOUR
ANALYSIS.
THERE'S A LOT THAT WENT INTO
THIS ANALYSIS.
YOU GO THROUGH SIX POTENTIAL
CRIMES IN HERE THAT TRUMP COULD
POSSIBLY FACE.
YOU SAY SOME ARE SLAM DUNK
CASES.
WHAT IS YOUR ULTIMATE CONCLUSION
HERE ON THIS?
>> SO WE DO THE EXERCISE THAT WE
IMAGINE THAT PROSECUTORS IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL DO AND
WHAT THEY'LL WANT TO PRESENT
GARLAND WITH, ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND WITH.
EVERY SINGLE CASE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE HAS EVER PROSECUTED
FOR THE SAME CRIME THEY ARE
ALLEGING, AT LEAST THERE WAS A
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE DONALD
TRUMP WAS INVOLVED IN.
WE LOOKED AT EVERY SINGLE CASE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEM ALL, THE
KINDS OF CONDUCT THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PROSECUTED IN
THE PAST ARE FAR LESSEE GREEJ
GOUS IN MOST OF THOSE CASES THAN
WHAT TRUMP IS ALLEGED TO HAVE
DONE WITH THE DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> THE PRECEDENT WOULD SHOW YOU
CHARGE AND YOU'RE SAYING
MULTIPLE POSSIBLE CHARGES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS DO YOU TREAT
LIKE CASES ALIKE?
IF YOU TREAT LIKE CASES ALIKE IT
BASICALLY FORCES THE CHOICE.
YOU HAVE TO CHARGE.
>> YOU HAVE TO CHARGE.
SO I WANT TO FOLLOW-UP ON THAT
ON EXACTLY WHAT THIS COULD MEAN.
FIRST, HIS DEFENSES.
HE'S GIVEN A LOT MUCH DEFENSES.
ONE, YOU'D BE TREATING ME
DIFFERENTLY.
NO, YOU WENT THROUGH APPLES TO
APPLES.
ACTUALLY, HE WOULD BE IF YOU
DIDN'T CHARGE HIM.
>> RIGHT.
>> THEY'VE ALSO SAID CERTAIN
THINGS LIKE YOU JUST HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT IT TO DECLASSIFY IT.
LET ME JUST PLAY A FEW OF THE
EXCUSES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT OUT
THERE.
>> REMEMBER THIS, REMEMBER THIS,
EVERYTHING WAS DECLASSIFIED.
THEY SHOULD GIVE ME IMMEDIATELY
BACK EVERYTHING THEY'VE TAKEN
FROM ME BECAUSE IT'S MINE.
>> I'M CONCERNED THEY MAY HAVE
PLANTED SOMETHING.
AT THIS POINT WHO KNOWS.
>> SHE OF COURSE IS ONE OF HIS
ATTORNEYS, ELENA IN THIS.
YOU GO THROUGH EACH OF THOSE.
ANY OF THEM ADD UP?
>> THEY JUST EVAPORATE UNDER
SCRUTINY.
WE DO TRY TO PLACE THEM ON THEIR
STRONGEST GROUND.
THERE IS A LOT THAT IS
INCONSISTENT.
IF YOU TAKE THEM ONE BY ONE AND
SAY IF THIS IS THE ALLEGATION,
HERE'S WHAT THE LAW SAYS, HERE'S
A BUNCH OF COMPETING FACTS THAT
DISPUTE THEIR DEFENSE AND IT
FALLS APART.
WE TRY TO DO THE MOST SERIOUS
ANALYSIS GIVING THEM THE MOST
FAVORABLE LIGHT AND IT DOESN'T
WORK.
>> YOU DON'T EVEN SAY THEY'VE
CONTRADICTED THEMSELVES.
GIVE EACH ONE 100% THE INPUT AND
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
OKAY.
SO WHERE DO YOU COME OUT ON HOW
MANY CHARGES SHOULD BY THIS
ANALYSIS BE PUT FORTH.
IF THOSE CHARGES COME TO
FRUITION, RIGHT, AND ARE PROVEN,
WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT ON HIM?
>> SO I THINK THE LEAD CHARGE
WOULD BE UNDER THE ESPIONAGE
ACT.
IT APPLIES HAND IN GLOVE TO THE
ACTIVITIES.
THERE ARE OTHER CHARGES.
THERE'S ANOTHER CHARGE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN TALKED ABOUT AS MUCH
WHICH IS THEFT OF GOVERNMENT
PROPERTY AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS IN FACT CHARGED
PEOPLE FOR THAT FOR CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
THERE WOULD BE A SECOND ONE.
A THIRD ONE WOULD BE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION.
SEEMS TO BE A STRONG CASE OF
THE INTERESTING PART IS EVEN
WITH VERY SENIOR OFFICIALS AND
LOWER DOWN OFFICIALS, THEY SEEM
TO CHARGE.
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER STORY TO
THIS.
THEY GET LIGHT SENTENCES IF THEY
PLEAD.
I DON'T SEE DONALD TRUMP DOING
THAT.
>> IN A NORMAL PERSON THIS WOULD
MEAN PRISON TIME?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> RYAN GOODMAN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THIS IS THE MODEL PROSECUTION
DOCUMENT ON THEIR BLOG.
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
ANALYSIS IN ALL OF ITS DETAIL.
THANKS AS ALWAYS.